Trump was talking about a band from
China back in January right yes he
instituted the ban I think 31st of
January that's when the band actually
happened but at the time the WETA was
saying that they shouldn't do it then
you shouldn't restrict travel to China
and shortly after that also the Chinese
foreign ministry said that they reacted
very badly to Trump's dancing that was
it was racism xenophobic so you
mentioned the whu-oh of the World Health
Organization and the CDC the Center for
Disease Control it seems like in the
last month a messaging out of the w-h-o
specifically has been just absolutely
all over the place and you know there's
some people that say oh well they didn't
want to push people into masks sort of
for the reasons you're saying because
then regular people who maybe don't need
them are gonna get all the masks the
people who need them won't have access
to them but have they as an organization
really just kind of flub this thing from
the beginning yeah absolutely the W
there's no question that the w-h-o has
you know basically abandoned its duties
in so many ways I mean you can go all
the way back to December you if you go
back to December 30th that's when China
first reported to the wh oh you know
that there were these cases you know
clustered about 41 people that was the
first time reported a day later on the
31st of January New Year's Eve one
basically said to the WH oh hey we have
heard that this is really serious and
that there's human to human transmission
there's also the 31st of December and
the reason Taiwan her knew about this
was because there were Taiwanese doctors
who had heard from their mainland
colleagues that the medical staff in
Wuhan were getting sick so that's how
you know him in the human transmissions
occurring it's when
you know it's not animal to person that
person a person is the patients are
transferring it to to the doctors so
Taiwan reports this and it takes weeks
before you know I think on the 14th of
January you still have that famous tweet
by by the WHL saying there's still no
evidence of human to human transmission
two weeks after - I want old them that
there was and and this has been the
story of how they've handled this
they've cow house yes wait let's just
let's just pause there for one sec
though let's just pause there for one
sec what is that like what do you think
structurally as someone that knows about
organizations like this like what
happened in those two weeks did were
they intentionally misleading us did
they just completely drop the ball was
there political pressure was it oh they
didn't want to be too alarmist I mean is
it some combination of all of those
things um no actually the problem is
that Taiwan doesn't have membership to
the w-h-o so China has very successfully
muscled Taiwan out so Taiwan's not
recognized as a member and and you know
for Taiwan that's very dangerous because
you know if you don't have that
connection to the WTO you are not
plugged into this global health alert
system and the global health alert
system is not plugged into Taiwan so
whatever Intel Taiwan had was completely
missed and then the worst part for
Taiwan is that because China basically
muscled them out when all the other
countries were placing travel bans they
were trying to ban you know China people
from China traveling to their countries
they inadvertently banned Taiwan because
Taiwan was seen as part China which is
what mm-hmm
okay so the w-h-o drops the ball and
then we've subsequently seen some other
strange tweets and we've seen some some
strange statements by by some of their
representatives Trump was talking about
a band from China back in January right
yeah
he instituted the ban I think 31st
January that's when the band actually
happened but at the time the WETA was
saying that they shouldn't do it then
you shouldn't restrict travel to China
and shortly after that also the Chinese
foreign ministry said that they reacted
very badly to Trump's dancing that was
it was racism xenophobic to the ban yeah
surprise surprise so what do you make of
the fact that now because hindsight is
20/20 people are saying Oh Trump didn't
do anything
in February everyone knew that this was
gonna happen Trump didn't do anything I
checked yesterday and it turns out that
do you know there was a democratic
debate on February I think it's 7th 19th
and 25th
none of those debates mentioned anything
about coronavirus oddly yet the media is
now telling us that everybody was
talking about all of this stuff in
February could could he have done more
should he have done more how do you
balance keeping people sane and keeping
the economy open versus a potential
looming threat all of that I mean he did
suggest that he was somewhat distracted
by the impeachment proceedings and for
the whole month of February you did have
our journalist class doing one of two
things saying that this was just you
know kind of the flu just not just
another flu or warning people about you
know that the stigma against Asian
Americans was worse than the virus
itself and so even on the 9th of
February you had the health officials in
New York City saying come out for a
Lunar New Year parade everything's okay
life is normal you know stand-up
no phobia and racism so they were still
acting as if understandably a lot of
people missed this you know it's okay so
it let's all just party and mix and and
you know stand in defiance to to this to
this virus so a lot of people missed it
but I read yesterday that on the 29th of
Jan that Pino Navarro who is the trade
official in Trump's cabinet actually
wrote the memo
warning and saying that this virus is
the real deal and there's going to be
you know at worst two million deaths at
best 100,000 but we gotta act on it and
he proposed actually a travel ban Trump
that he didn't read the memo but shortly
after on the 31st he actually he
actually did put down the travel ban
that's one of the you know the good
things about Trump is that he didn't
really care about that and this this
virus actually really fit in well with
his ideological priors you know for
being conservative on immigration and
being a bit more nationalistic in terms
of trade and engagement America first
yeah
can you talk a little bit about just
like the inner machinations of China
because right now it's like just in the
last few days we've seen this thing
where you know US cases are spiking but
China is reporting no new cases no new
debts and it's like alright well just be
and then NBC News will literally make
that statement the AP will make that
statement and it's like well I guess
that's sort of reporting and that you're
reporting what China is reporting but
that's not really independent reporting
like can you talk a little bit about how
information can or can't travel in China
you know the media's job is to be
skeptical and towards that and they are
very skeptical of the Coates reporting
about the Trump administration they're
not affording that same approach to the
Chinese government one of all people who
interested me skeptical about it should
be numbers that are coming off a very
closed or terraeum society and you know
I don't think I think China has had a
history of covering up numbers in
general people are very skeptical about
even numbers coming out from their GDP
calculations how they miraculously
always meet exactly six percent target
like exact so they have a history of
hide anything in fact that they had no
qualms suppressing the whistleblower
censoring their their social media why
you know why wouldn't they we not su
that they're they're covering up their
their numbers so if we can't trust the
numbers that were getting out of China
and sadly we can't really trust our own
media to report on it properly rather
than just regurgitate the numbers how do
we get some sensible information out of
China is there a way to do it that you
can truly trust well you know the CIA
apparently they they submitted
classified to the white fellows a
bloomberg reported on and they actually
basically said that they were trying to
hide China numbers and we were able to
so you know apart from intelligence
agencies or using some sort of proxy I
think a lot of people saw these videos
that were circulated in social media all
the urns that were you know going to a
funeral home and to match up with with
what was reported probably a lot of
these videos once they get posted by
citizen journalists hands it up you know
they ended up getting taken down for
class so information out of Chinese just
Ohio and I mean unfortunately the only
thing that we have to submitting to the
whu-oh Hebburn we're obviously in some
unchartered territory with coronavirus
and our plan here is to help you make as
much sense of the situation and a non
alarmist fashion as possible if you're
looking for reliable information from
experts on the front lines of the
pandemic check out our coronavirus
playlist which will keep adding updates
- right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe